bienvenidos a enlace conosur desde
uruguay en el programa del día de hoy
hablaremos de seguridad pública y la
escalada de homicidios que se viene
registrando en el país en los últimos
meses también conoceremos como el peso
uruguayo logró ser la moneda más fuerte
de la región incluso por encima del real
brasileño además luego del cambio de
gobierno en chile uruguay viene
experimentando un aumento en las
inversiones chilenas
especialmente en bienes raíces
los crímenes violentos se han convertido
en la principal preocupación de los
uruguayos según cifras oficiales en los
primeros seis meses del 2022 se
registraron 188 homicidios que hace un
40% más de lo ocurrido en el mismo
periodo del año anterior y casi un 9%
por encima de lo ocurrido en el 2019 la
situación de alerta
agrava cuando ocurren casos que
involucran a niños o aparecen en cuerpos
desmembrados una reciente encuesta
indica que el 62% de los uruguayos
considera que la gestión del gobierno en
seguridad pública es negativa lo que
implica un gran problema para la
administración de luis lacalle pou quien
ganó las elecciones en 2019 con la
seguridad como uno de sus argumentos más
fuertes durante la campaña electoral fue
justamente la escalada de delitos
durante la gestión anterior del frente
amplio lo que según analistas políticos
entre otros temas provocó su derrota
electoral tras 15 años en el gobierno
ahora como oposición el frente amplio
exige una política de estado para
solucionar el tema de seguridad y
afirman no se está haciendo lo
suficiente en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico y el lavado de activos al
momento que es
vuelve la normalidad o vuelve la
actividad
hay un incremento sostenido de los
delitos más graves que son aquellos
delitos que tienen relación con la
integridad física pero nosotros estamos
viviendo una situación compleja en
materia de seguridad y convivencia
y enfrente no tenemos una política
pública adecuada la visión del ministro
del interior luis alberto heber es muy
diferente indicó que se deben considerar
las estadísticas de todos los delitos y
destacó una tendencia a la baja por
ejemplo en hurtos y rapiñas hoy los
uruguayos vivimos más seguros a mi
juicio y lo voy a probar que en el 2019
y ustedes verán hay descenso en todos
los delitos 23 por ciento de los
homicidios
19 con 9 por ciento no hurto 18 con
8% en rapiñas porque hacemos esta
comparación bueno porque estos números
fueron cuestionados en el sistema
político de que se debían a que
estábamos en pandemia
o sea que no había mérito de la policía
en otros temas el peso uruguayo se ha
conformado en la moneda con mejor
desempeño en sudamérica con ganancias
por encima del 11% frente al dólar
estadounidense los principales
beneficiados con este valor del peso han
sido los asalariados que pueden acceder
más fácilmente a productos importados
por el uruguayo sale a viajar con más
facilidad que en otros momentos puede
comprar productos importados por ejemplo
cambiar el auto comprar
electrodomésticos cambiar la televisión
el celular a un costo mucho menor que
nosotros que nosotros pedidos históricos
del país entre tanto al sector
exportador la caída del precio de la
divisa en uruguay le preocupa dado los
elevados costos de producción estamos
teniendo la suerte de que los precios
internacionales de los principales
productos de exportación del uruguay
carne
arroz leche celulosa se encuentran en
niveles muy elevados han tenido una suma
muy fuerte en los últimos años y eso ha
compensado la ecuación de costos el
mercado de bienes raíces en uruguay vive
un importante auge producto de cambios
en la legislación que promueve la
inversión y la estabilidad económica y
política que ofrece el país eso generó
que aumentara la cantidad de
proyectos tanto en montevideo como en el
interior de la presentación y de empezar
los proyectos que vamos en el 2019 eran
73 proyectos que estaban presentados y
en el 2021 eran 181 motivados por los
cambios que avecinan en su país muchos
inversores chilenos se han interesado
por uruguay tanto para invertir en
propiedades en las grandes ciudades como
en campos productivos el valor del metro
cuadrado en santiago de chile- comparado
por ejemplo con el de montevideo es
apenas mayor pero la rentabilidad en el
país trasandino es de 3 y 4% mientras
que en el charrúa es del 4 al 6 por
ciento el interés de los chilenos empezó
te diría a fines del año pasado
noviembre de diciembre a tener con
continuas consultas este para invertir
en uruguay
el inversor chileno es un inversor que
no es primerizo ya ha invertido en otros
lugares y sabe bien lo que quiere otro
importante incentivo para los inversores
chilenos es poder obtener la residencia
fiscal así como también la vacación
fiscal vigente
de este modo llegamos al final de enlace
conosur desde uruguay continúe con
nosotros en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]